a breton gentleman appointed member of the
european commission by the
european council after the vote of approval by
the european parliament i solemnly undertake
to respect the treaties
and the charter of fundamental rights of
the european union in the performance of
all my duties  to exercise my
responsibilities in full independence
in the general interest of the union in
the performance of my tasks to neither
seek nor accept instructions
from any government
instruction bodies or organizations to
refrain from any act incompatible
with the character  of my duties or
the performance of the same floor I take note
of the obligation established by the treaty on
the functioning of the European union
under which each member state
must respect this character and not
seek to influence the members of the
commission in the performance of their
duties,
I further undertake to respect, during
the term of office and after the
termination thereof, the obligation  s
arising from my office, in particular the
duty of honesty and delicacy with
regard to the acceptance after this
cessation of certain functions of
certain advantages
[Applause]
thank you, Madame fait reindeer